[Music]
all right y'all so there's a lot going
on right now in Ecuador really oh yeah
mhm damn I don't well I don't know cash
me up to speeds oh Jo you're going to
like this one Joe all right okay so
basically there's a giant crisis going
on right now and Ecuador has been
declared in a state of War oh [__] okay
uh recently they announced a state of
emergency after a leader of one of the
country's top two Gam escaped from
prison the following day game members
stormed the TC television news program
broadcasting their hostage taking and
violence live to make an announcement of
their own so they literally stormed news
station like masks and guns and
everything like that Anderson Cooper get
inter ter [__] [__] crazy sh Anderson
Cooper is he's like has a gun in his
face and they're like making him get on
the floor and [__] y because the two
gang leaders were able to escape from
prison one of them yeah yeah and what
appeared to be a coordinated campaign
one uh that basically kind of recalls
the the OG like mid 2010 Mexico cartel
stuff armed men stormed hospitals
businesses and universities prisons were
taken over in violent riots bombs were
set off in multiple locations so it was
all done at once simultaneously and
police and prison guards were kidnapped
and
murdered at least 10 people were killed
in gang attacks including police and
over 100 prison staff were taken hostage
isn't that crazy how like El Salvador is
like the complete opposite where they
took out the gangs and all this and now
Ecuador is like a gang country and El
sador did Bitcoin reserves that was lit
for them they made money off of it
that's
smart yeah so Ecuador is in a state of
emergency America's pretty [__] cool
man so Ecuador is it why cuz it Gavin
new's kind of sick huh did America beat
them I mean did they did America fund
that no it's just America it's like
America sick did America fund that no
when you see like other countries how
easy how delicate their society is it's
like tissue paper is you know like for
us like right I just read um the Texas
National Guard like relieved the federal
border patrol right did you did you guys
see that whated the T the Texas National
so like you know how there's like
federal laws Federal initiatives and
there state laws and state initiatives I
think Texas is going like you know we're
tired the the way you guys are handling
the Border oh I saw that you federal
agents get out of here and now the Texas
Military aka the National Guard aka the
Army is now replacing that oh right and
the FEDS are suing them now right yeah
but it's cool that like our [__] is like
like falling up oh it's like you're in
competent so the citizens or the state
police is going to get together and
[__] State military though California
ain't doing that [__] yeah California
it's like pretty much like Ecuador cnia
wack yeah yeah California is like
Ecuador but I think yeah too I think
it's wack but there's other states and
overall the ideology of America is how
do we make things better you know
exactly we got got to go against the
government and
California and California Bas as hell is
still way far away from where Ecuador is
and so you still feel like oh man
America's got problems but it's kind of
a tight place you see all those Chinese
people that got stopped at the border
trying to uh to [__] come into
America as well good a ton of them dude
stop those [__] dude you saw the
military haircuts and everything I've
been seeing a lot of that footage it's
pretty wild even RFK Jun I think so I
feel like one day they're going to be
like sheap P going to be like it's
time
all [__] like what happened to Ecuador
just like what's going to happen to
Ecuador could be all at once you know
there's mil now that's how e to do
millions of like illegal uh that's crazy
how many how many got in yeah it's nuts
it's [__] I was like Millions sing
for Elon right now like we always do
dude I don't know mil to me it's like
hundreds of thousands is normal Millions
I don't know how we're going to be able
to take care of like that many people
coming in we can't we're not seeing
anyone take care of send them back look
what happened in New York they're
they're they're taking care I thought
they were a sanctuary City they can't
take care of them but they changed their
mind they they they didn't they didn't
want to stay they didn't want to stay in
the sanctuary they gave them the hotel
to live in they weren't allowed to cook
so they all left and then they uh
started moving in people's trucks D and
they can't get them out of the truck cuz
the city won't do it if there's kids in
the truck and all these families have I
vote for go to Beverly [__] Hills go
go outside Oprah's house go outside all
these people's houses who who want all
their [__] y hell yeah I agree they
tried they tried to do that I'm they
sent them right back remember yeah they
sure did I'm going hop in the crowd I
want to live in Oprah's house let me in
pretend I'm an illegal
hey dude so there's like a you speak
English that's true but they are saying
let me in that's the only thing they say
is if they're illegal they just say let
me in the whole time he got us there let
me
in saying it again there's a so they
declared it a state of War but does that
mean like it's Civil War cuz everyone's
been saying Civil War like it's some
kind of a it's not a civil war if it's a
criminal organization it's like a
terrorist takeover yeah why are they
saying that it's also really hard
because um there's a huge Vine for power
right now between like two different
gangs right and especially because we're
Ecuador is in between what is it like
Peru and Colombia so they're like in the
middle of like huge cocaine
manufacturing countries and
organizations already so where they are
territorially there's already so many
different people vying for like
territorial war and stuff so you're
having like what might seem like Civil
War is infighting maybe between like
gang you know two two notorious gangs
out there we got a DM from uh JK IG DM
from some Ecuadorian guy and he was he
was saying he's in Ecuador uh I think
he's he might be or his maybe his whole
family is but he said that it people
there's a lot more people being caught
in the middle where it's like civilians
yeah because because at this time
they're not taking any chances and
they're classifying certain people as
being allies to the uh the cartels and
the gangs so it's like you may not be
it's like you have to choose really
wisely what you're going to do you no
one has nothing to do with it basically
so it's like their two largest gangs Los
Lobos and Los cheros which have
maintained kind of like an uneasy piece
um until the assassinations of gang
leaders in 2020 like that created a huge
power struggle since then groups have
rapidly splintered into factions vying
for control of territory particularly
guak uh apparently and which is I think
an area where they they do a lot of like
trade and trafficking uh experts say
foreign criminal groups took sides with
those gangs so that means like Los Lobos
are believed to be Tethered to halisco
New Generation wo Toros are are in
Alliance with caloa so it's actually
Mexico playing like people like coming
in there because it's like in the middle
of both territories of Peru and Colombia
I mean that's like every war
everywhere so they're playing Russia and
Ukraine but it's like Mexican cartel's
playing freaking movie yeah we're living
in a [__] movie man you know Paraguay
I heard is a very safe country foxy
wory and it's right next to Ecuador
that's why you have to train does this
affect vacation prices in the area yeah
it's that your thing whenever the rates
are I usually go when after a massive
terrorist attack or something because
it's usually really really great pricing
and play are on discount a lot of people
are so stupid they don't know where
Ecuador is but the way I remembered when
I was a kid is like it's on the
equator oh that makes sense that's why
it's Ecuador it's equator door it's the
door to the equator you just pass Mexico
and all the you just Peru on by Peru yep
Peru in Indiana's where all the Indians
let me in let me in in Indiana's where
all the Indians are right
yep yep
pleasee thank you thank you DN dude I
want to go there right now oh yeah right
now is the best time to go I think you I
think Asians need to stay out of South
America for a long time I think this I
think it's still on fire Ecuador I wish
I could speak Spanish because me too one
of those countries are very unstable and
they need a leader yeah but I can't
speak Spanish I can't I faed Spanish
four times y long time so it's like the
president has zero say it's just they
took over the news station they're just
like two gangs fighting each other it's
almost as if Government doesn't exist
CRA thing n nboa the president had I
believe President has said that or
issued a decree that designated over 20
gangs as terrorist groups and authorized
the Ecuador's military to neutralize
them so I think it is like an internal
arm conflict but now he's wow basically
getting the Ecuadorian military to also
take action so I think it's going to
turn into a giant cluster [__] of War
War if you will news station got handled
sorry the news station got handled yeah
so they basically had military and
police stuff come down and a bunch of
people were arrested but like at the
same time they had like they took over
prisons they took over Hospital you know
what I mean it was an entire different
thing the news one was just literally on
live news so that's why it was like
super broadcasted what if we made all
these leaders have to listen to overly
explaining white ladies on Tik talk
about peace and that's true you know
what I'm saying it actually might chill
out I think that's why they put up that
content is they know that this will work
but like we just have to make these guys
watch it I think the problem is they
don't speak English and if more people
spoke English they would actually be
listening to the blue-haired ladies on
Tik Tok right so if we invade more
countries and make them learn English
then the messages understand their own
toxic masculinity exactly thank you I
think if they took therapy they
definitely wouldn't be doing this toxic
M I think these leaders have social
anxiety and they just mask it with L
these go easy on masculine traits I'm
just always so proud that we can always
come to these understandings for these
like huge problems and conflicts in the
world but like we have maturity to bring
it's literally small man patriarchy [__]
like Tiny Dick boys who drive trucks
what I white trucks giant white
trucks small my small subin what should
they
do who who the gangs The Gangs keep
going you doing a good job
no keep it coming man people got to
understand there's no more peace in this
[__] world you see Ukraine Russia you
see uh uh the protest Afghan Iraq people
inside America there's the left there's
the right keep it going you know what
just keep it going till it's all wiped
up keep keep the going keep Prof keep
the conf no I'm just no no but we should
be peace you know what I mean at the end
of the
day no but come on let's be let's be
honest people want people peace but
people have we have to understand there
is no such thing there's no such thing
as
peace what did Define
peace right now right here right here
right now that's a good answer I don't
feel very peaceful about this guy see
want PE with
me I think I do I love it oh I would
love
it